(applause)
Thank you.
Thank you everybody for
coming in this evening.
A renowned faculty member
in the School of the
Arts and Architecture,
Cathy Opie, on of the
world's great photographers,
and not just great
teachers of photography,
has said many times a simple point:
Ideas always start with questions.
That is the frame and the format
for the next 10 weeks in this course.
If you'll allow me to take a few minutes,
I'd like, as this is our first session,
to briefly introduce the course,
and then I'll turn to a short introduction
of tonight's session,
and question and introduce
each of our terrific guests
here on the stage this evening.
I'm Brett Steele,
Dean of the UCLA School of
the Arts and Architecture,
and here tonight, very
much as a faculty member,
and a member of a larger
office that has done
a huge amount of work in
recent weeks to put together
what I know is gonna be a
terrific new kind of course
here on campus this quarter here at UCLA.
It's a course that's been
designed with the input,
thinking and advice of many people,
not just up in my office,
but across the entire school,
and I'll thank them at the
end of this introduction.
Tonight's first session,
which I'll introduce, I've
decided, not in total tonight,
and maybe it's because
of several years' work
as an editor, and not
only author of books,
but I like to sprinkle
an introduction across
each of the 10 weeks for our students.
One of the things I've learned
as an editor is usually
an introduction is best
if it's written at the end
of all of the hard work
of putting the ideas
and content and materials together.
But I would like to
offer two or three points
to get this course going.
What I thought I would
talk about very briefly
is something of the form of this course,
its format, and for our
students in attendance,
a little bit about its
weekly organization.
And I promise you only a few highlights.
So, on the topic of form,
this is a course that, by design,
seeks to do one thing above all else,
which is ask questions,
questions that are
posed as a way to simply
open conversations about the ways in which
important ideas and
important questions posed
from the vantage of the
arts can be thought about,
and work can be done on through the lens,
the life experiences,
the professional experiences,
the ideas that each of our guests
will bring to that question
from their own lives and careers.
For those of you up on this stage tonight,
this is the first of, and
a new experimental format
that will bring together
40 terrific faculty members
across the entire campus,
not just the leafy
north end of campus here
that we in the arts love so much,
for the purpose of a larger conversation
around these ideas.
One of its important
ambitions you could say
is in fact to create
bridges of various kinds
here on campus.
It's not a bad intent, I think,
at a time in which so
many parts of the world
talk about things like walls and borders
in more ways than we can imagine
really are being struck up
in new and unexpected ways.
Those borders exist also
in things like campuses
in this day and age.
Really wonderful, incredible
work being done within schools
too often operates in isolation
of the many other interesting schools,
forms of knowledge and
fields of experience
that make up the amazing
city-state of a university
like UCLA today.
It's a community of about 80,000 people.
As you know, the smallest,
I think most of you will know,
geographically the
smallest of the campuses
in the UC system,
and owing to its population,
for that reason also,
its densest.
One of the things we would
like to take advantage of
is what that density might
offer to bring us all together
periodically in unexpected ways around,
at times, unfamiliar questions that let us
think about our own work in new,
interesting and unexpected ways.
Regarding the form of this course,
and as a minor concessions
to the history of art,
there is a form of symmetry involved
in how we've designed it.
Every one of these Tuesday evenings
will feature two members of our faculty
from the School of the
Arts and Architecture,
and two members from the wider faculties
across all of the other schools,
and research settings
that will come together
to talk about these questions.
- [Paul] Actually on
this field, (mumbles).
- Yeah.
That wasn't choreographed,
(laughing)
but, yes, there does seem
to be clear lines drawn.
We'll work on that.
I hope the conversation can do work
on that symmetry going forward.
Okay, so the second important bridge,
just to mention very briefly
as this is our first session,
that we're looking at doing work on
with the design of the course is in fact
two very different kinds
of audience members
here in terrific
auditorium in Kaufman Hall.
The first audience
member here this evening
is, of course, the
students that have enrolled
in this course formally,
and will be doing coursework
and work in fact beyond
these evenings every week
over the next 10 weeks
of this autumn quarter.
For those of you students
that have come in tonight,
thank you, and thank
you for taking time away
from that part of the day often directed
towards things like dinner,
cocktails with friends,
(audience laughing)
Tuesday night football or whatever else
fills one's life here on campus.
In all seriousness,
thank you for taking time
and coming in for that.
For you to also be aware,
the students enrolled in this course
interestingly include not
just students enrolled
in one of the four facilities
here in the school,
which includes architecture
and urban design,
art, design, media arts,
world arts, culture, dance,
but in addition to those departments,
departments in the two other
schools of arts here in UCLA,
theater, film, television, and music.
So we get an opportunity to bring together
students from those three
different arts schools
here on campus, and in
fact from further afield.
As some of you students know already,
we have students tonight
here in the session
that are enrolled and studying right now
in departments of neuroscience, biology,
French, political science,
many other departments,
including forms of knowledge
further afield than arts regularly,
like financial actuarial mathematics.
So thank you very much for coming in
and being a part of this sort of audience.
As a school, we take
very seriously the idea
in fact that a great school
of the arts and architecture
sees the making of audiences,
the choregraphy of audiences,
as an essential part of its work,
and in fact it's embedded in
the history of this school,
from the moment it opened in venues
like Royce Hall and others
over the last century,
in which the bringing
together of public audience
is understood as a really essential part,
not just of our mission as a university,
but of what a school like ours
does in training individuals
in various creative fields,
where that work is always
best done in close proximity
and regular interaction with audiences
where ideas are formed and play out.
That's all about the form of this course.
Regarding format,
really just one point to remind you all,
each week one big question has been posed.
That question will be
approached, as I said earlier,
from the different disciplines
and forms of expertise that'll be up here
on the stage every week.
My job will be, as my day
job involves regularly
a moderating and facilitating
of the conversation
that I hope to be able
to keep going forward,
following on from each
of the introductions
that our guests will make at the beginning
of this session.
And finally, as I said
earlier about the organization
of this course for you students,
as a larger group, you of course will meet
in four smaller sessions,
sections, throughout the week,
and in those sections, have an opportunity
to literally rehearse and
rework the kind of conversation
and discussion that'll
take place upon the stage
starting off that week,
with an idea that you will participate,
very much like our guests
that are up here on the stage.
And that's really it,
as a few words about the larger course.
As this is the first
session of the quarter,
if I could just take a couple
of minutes of everybody's time
to thank the big group of people
that have really made this possible,
and who confirmed for
us the extent to which
an event like this is simply one edge
of a much larger space of
activity and invention.
A terrific group of
people have come together
to help make this sort of course possible.
In addition to you all as audience
and our guests here tonight
for taking the time of coming in,
two vice provosts here at UCLA
have been especially important
in making this possible.
Tim Brewer, our Vice Provost
for Interdisciplinary Activities
and Cross-Campus Affairs
has been very supportive
in providing funding,
as had Roger Wakimoto, our
Vice Provost for Research,
which has supported this
for his belief that in fact
the work we do as artists,
the designers, performers,
is research of a different
and important kind
here on campus.
We have four brilliant
TAs that our students here
will all get to know well this term.
Jing Jing, Kyle, Haley and Anna,
thank you for taking
time out of your studies
to come together and be
a part of this course.
From my office, Anne Marie Burke,
our Executive Director of
Comms and Public Relations
has played a huge part in
putting all of this together
in the same space and time.
And in her office,
Louise Kale and Kylie Carrigan have done
a really important part of
expanding what will take place
here on the stage,
and a larger online digital space
that all of you students
in the wider audience
will have access to
over the next 10 weeks.
Jennifer Wells Green,
our Executive Director of Development,
has played a really
important part of managing
the big audience of
people who wanna come in
and be a part of this event,
and Victoria Marks especially,
who is right in front of me
with a phone reminding
me it's time to finish
this introduction, and who
is, in addition to being
the Associate Dean of Academic
Affairs here in the school,
a brilliant choregrapher and
professor of her own right,
and, in fact, the person
who has choreographed this
in such a tremendous way.
We have a couple of media partners,
KCRT and KCRW,
who are a part of this
event in various ways
in supporting our activities,
and this bigger mission of taking this out
to a public audience.
And finally, we have to thank
our Department of World
Arts, Culture, Dance
for a huge amount of support
in not just providing us a lovely room
that I think we're gonna enjoy
over the next couple of months,
but providing all of
the technical expertise
that does things like turn the lights on
and make these microphones
work in magical ways.
So everybody, thank you
for coming in for this.
I'm gonna now introduce briefly
tonight's guests and
tonight's first session.
(applause)
Thank you.
(audience applause)
For that, let me try and
do that from sitting down.
One of our ambitions was to
take things like lecterns
and PowerPoint and other
modern appliances away from
a discussion of ideas and
forms of teaching and learning,
so we're gonna try this sitting down.
We'll work on our projection.
Please tell us if we're
struggling in that.
Tonight's question, What Is Space?
is the first of 10 questions
that this course is gonna
be organized around.
Space is a concept, a term and a word
that particularly amongst
fields like architecture
have been important to
signaling the very idea
of a modern world.
It's not so much that space
didn't exist before modern
architects in the early
20th Century claimed it.
It's that there was a realization
the construction of built space
became a means for thinking
about what the very idea
of a modern subject might be in our world.
It's the only clue I'll give you
that an architect has helped curate
this series of questions,
which will look at a number of
different areas very quickly
as we get through space this evening.
Our guests tonight
are four really amazing
faculty members here at UCLA,
and who will help us literally launch
what we hope is a multi-year effort
to extend these kind of conversations
from campus to Los
Angeles to the West Coast
to the United States and across the world
in the coming years when we work through
iterations of this kind of a format.
And if you'll allow me,
I'd just like to very briefly introduce
each of our four guests, who have agreed,
by means of a decision making
process I'm unfamiliar with,
a running order for who will speak first.
But let me just first
introduce each of these
four guests very briefly.
Dana Cuff on my right here.
Dana joins us this evening
from the Department of
Architecture and Urban Design
here in the School of
Arts and Architecture.
Dana is a professor
of Architecture and Urban
Design here at UCLA,
where she is also Director of cityLAB,
an award-winning think tank
that advances experimental
urbanism and architecture.
Since receiving her PhD in
architecture from Berkeley,
Dana has published and lectured widely
about spatial justice,
the architectural profession,
and affordable housing.
She is the author of several books,
including The Provisional City,
about housing in Los Angeles,
and based upon cityLAB studies,
Dana coauthored a
landmark bill that permits
backyard homes on
virtually all eight million
single-family properties in California,
enabling a doubling of
built density of the suburbs
across the entire state
here in California.
(audience applause)
- Rodrigo Valenzuela joins us this evening
from the School of the
Arts and Architecture,
where he is Assistant
Professor of Photography
in our Department of Art.
Born in Chile and based in Los Angeles,
Rodrigo is an artist
working in photography,
video, painting, and installation.
His work constructs narrative scenes
and stories that point to the tensions
between the individuals and communities
that inhabit our cities and world.
Much of his work deals with the experience
of undocumented immigrants and laborers.
Rodrigo earned his MFA in Photo Media
at the University of Washington,
his BA in Philosophy from
Evergreen State College,
and a BFA in Art History and Photography
from the University of Chile.
Rodrigo's work has been
exhibited extensively
internationally, including
recent shows in Vienna,
the Ulrich Museum of Art in Wichita,
the Frye Art Museum in Seattle,
the Museo de Arte
Contemporaneo in Santiago,
the Drawing Center in New York,
and many, many others.
(applause)
On my left and far left,
Andrea Ghez is Professor
of Astronomy and Physics
here at UCLA.
Andrea is a world leading expert
in observational astrophysics,
and has used the Keck
telescopes to suggest
the existence of a
super massive black hole
at the center of our galaxy
with a mass four million
times that of the sun,
which is big.
- Four million?
- Really big.
- Very big.
(laughs)
Andrea earned her BS in physics from MIT,
her PhD from Caltech,
and has been on faculty in the Department
of Physics and Astronomy
at UCLA since 1994.
Andrea has actively disseminated
her work and thinking
to a wide variety of audiences
through more than 100 referee papers
and 200 invited talks,
as well as features in textbooks,
documentaries and science exhibits.
Her numerous honors and prizes include
being the first woman to receive
the Crafoord Prize, a
MacArthur fellowship,
and she's been elected to the
National Academy of Sciences
and the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
(applause)
And finally, tonight includes Paul Weiss.
Paul is a nanoscientist,
a distinguished Professor
of Material Science and Engineering,
distinguished Professor of
Chemistry and Biochemistry,
and a UC Presidential Chair.
Paul's interdisciplinary research group
includes chemists, physicists, biologists,
material scientists, electrical
and mechanical engineers
and computer scientists.
Their work focuses on the
atomic scale properties
of surface and supramolecular assemblies.
And I've been practicing
supramolecular in advance of this.
(laughing)
Paul received his SB and SM
degrees in Chemistry from MIT,
his PhD in Chemistry from
the University of California
at Berkeley.
He was a postdoctoral member
of the technical staff
at Bell Labs,
a visiting scientist at IBM
Almaden Research Center before
becoming Director of the
California NanoSystems Institute,
Professor of Chemistry and
Biochemistry here at UCLA,
and Fred Kavli Chair in
Nanosystems Sciences.
With his students, Paul has
developed new techniques
to expand the applicability
of scanning probe microscopes,
and works to advance nanofab
reaction to ever smaller scales
and greater chemical
specificity to connect,
operate and test molecular devices.
(applause)
- Ready now?
- Paul will be our first speaker tonight.
To remind you all,
we've organized this so
that each of our guests
will open the evening
with a short presentation,
after which we'll have a conversation
around some of the things presented.
- [Paul] Great.
Well, it's a fantastic honor to kick off
this series and first round.
I thought, given the current times,
(audience laughing)
we should start with beer,
politics and religion.
(audience laughing)
Joseph Priestly really
ushered in the modern era
in chemistry, and he liked beer too.
(audience laughing)
He did something useful with it though.
He discovered an isolated carbon dioxide,
and then he also invented soda water,
which our hosts were
kind enough to bring me.
He didn't commercialize it though.
His contemporary JJ Schweppes did,
and made a lot of money from it.
So, really, the idea of
atoms came from Democritus
a couple of millennia earlier,
but there were arguments
over what made up matter,
us, everything around us,
and by isolating and identifying
individual molecules,
Priestly was able to settle that dispute
and usher in the idea of
atoms making up molecules.
Shortly thereafter, that
theory of chemistry developed.
We were able to make new compounds,
and in the thinking, and the
reason I wanna bring this up,
the thinking at the time was
about those component elements,
and because we didn't have
any way to visualize them,
but we couldn't do much else either,
we thought of atoms and
the things they made.
That continued through
the early 20th century,
and the quantum theory and understanding
the orbitals of atoms and so forth.
I should point out a few
other things about Priestly.
He was the founder of
the Unitarian Church.
He considered Benjamin Franklin a hero,
but Benjamin Franklin also championed him,
and when his house was burned down
and he was in trouble in England,
Franklin helped arrange
for him to come to America,
and he spent the last
years of his life here.
Okay, this pointer is
about to die by the way,
so it must need batteries.
I wanted to say something
about orbitals and space.
In what we do in nanoscience
and in chemistry,
we think about atoms.
We don't think about the nuclei so much,
except under special circumstances.
Those are 100,000 times smaller,
and not usually relevant
to the work that we do
in putting together the pieces and matter.
There's some special cases where
we can use them to advantage.
If you look in a...
Ah, this is advancing, right.
(audience laughing)
Someone rearranged the buttons.
What's that?
- [Crew Member] Is it on?
- It is on.
Yes, see.
But you advanced it somehow.
Okay, there we go.
Back to here.
So, nuclei are small.
Those have a positive charge.
The electrons around them
are what make up chemistry,
what we can visualize with the microscopes
that we've developed,
and they're the glue that holds molecules,
materials and all of us together.
So, up through the time that
we understood these orbitals,
everything was fine and
we thought this way.
But as we developed new techniques,
as we made solids and looked at them,
we kinda gave up the idea in our head
that we could imagine
those individual atoms.
And it wasn't until about the 1980s,
there were a few glimmers
in the '50s and '60s,
but really the '80s that
microscopes were developed
that could imagine individual atoms
by scanning a metal
needle across the surface
and really feeling the electrons
of the atoms on the surface.
We're missing something, I think, right?
Oh, no, sorry, right.
This is...
Some of you are old
enough to remember manuals
that had this page
intentionally left blank.
This is saying we lost the
idea of individual atoms,
and we thought about things
in periodic structures
and so forth.
Forget my own joke.
That is not the end of
the slideshow, though.
(laughing)
Can you fix the slides?
There's another one right after that.
Okay, no problem.
(laughing)
So, this microscope is
developed that let us
image individual atoms,
and we were excited that all of the sudden
this nanoscale world opened up to us,
and it really changed our thinking back.
It looks like you have...
Something got hidden?
No?
Yeah.
Okay, I can talk.
So...
(laughing)
Never stopped me before.
So not only could we
image individual atoms,
but we could look at the
orbitals in a sense, like...
There we go.
Okay.
This was hard to describe otherwise.
So here's different scales,
(laughing)
starting with red blood cells.
We're at a few microns here.
We can look at all these devices,
go down to DNA at a couple
of nanometers across,
where it's of course made
up of individual atoms.
But when Watson and Crick
took Rosalind Franklin's data
and got the structure of
the double helix of DNA,
they didn't really get the
positions of all the atoms,
they didn't get the sequence
of the DNA and so forth.
That came later, through
some decades of technology.
I'll point out a couple
of related pieces here.
A virus, we were just talking
about this in the prelude,
is made up of atoms.
It's a precise structure
that nature builds
from the bottom up.
My wife is a neuroscientist.
She pointed out that the
brain has always been nano,
that technology and scientists are just
millions of years behind,
and our technology in
making semiconductor devices
has just now reached that same scale.
And so a project that we have together
is to try and understand what a thought is
and what a memory is
by trying to listen in
on the communication
between cells and the brain,
listen in to the hundred
different chemicals
that are used for signaling.
Now in nature,
these structures are
built from the bottom up.
Chemistry, assembly,
these are examples of
supramolecular assemblies.
In most of what humans
do, we use top-down,
or, essentially, direct ascendance
of wood and stone carving
that we've done for centuries.
Bill Murray got to be pretty good
at ice sculpting in the
end of Groundhog Day.
But one of the strategies we use now
is to say can we make precise
or functional structures
from the bottom up?
Can we make bigger and bigger precise,
or sufficiently precise
structures to understand
and control their properties,
or, for instance, to
interact with the brain?
The scale of biology is the nanoscale,
and so we have this opportunity
to develop these interactions.
Okay, now, a little bit
about how important space is.
Carbon monoxide, the poison,
was also isolated by Priestly.
He didn't know it, but he did
know that it was poisonous.
He got CO2.
In a steel mill, you may
know the last reaction
that produces energy is
taking carbon monoxide to...
Oh, okay, this didn't transfer correctly,
but I'll tell you it's only in
the third digit of precision
that the spacing of the
carbon and the oxygen atoms
are different between carbon
monoxide and carbon dioxide.
There's a tremendous energetic
difference between those two.
For those of you who take high
school or freshman chemistry,
have a look at the
difference between single,
double and triple bonds in carbon,
things like acetylene, ethylene to ethane.
There are very tiny differences
that are a factor of one, two and three,
in terms of those bond strengths.
So getting those separations right,
whether we're understanding
them or replacing them,
makes a very big difference.
That's all the chemistry
we need to know for now.
Okay.
Now, we can image individual atoms.
This was from the time I was at IBM.
This is a distorted image.
This is a single xenon atom,
which turns out to be
my favorite rare gas.
You know when you breathe
helium, it makes your voice high.
If you breathe xenon,
it makes your voice low.
It also has an anesthetic effect,
so if you do this during...
We're being recorded, that's okay.
If you do this during a
freshman chemistry lecture,
you would have to pour
it out of your lungs
because it's too heavy to diffuse out,
and you risk passing out,
and so I always have TAs in the front,
ready to hold me upside down by my ankles
to drain it outta me.
It has kind of an anesthetic effect too,
so it's no good to lecture.
You do it right at the
end of the lecture. Okay.
Back to xenon.
So, this isn't the size of a xenon atom
that we know from other measurements.
This is where the electrons
are around the xenon atom.
And so for the physicists involved,
this seemed like something
of a disappointment.
I'll point out that each one of these
very, very shallow
protrusions is a nickel atom,
and that's because the
electrons that form the bonds
between them smooth out so much.
And we had to blow up this scale
just to make the figure interesting.
Well, there's much more we
can do with these microscopes,
it turned out.
So, I chose this particular
image because to me
it's the most important one ever recorded.
It has two different
atoms, gallium and arsenic.
You don't have to know anything about them
other than that arsenic likes
electrons more than gallium.
And so all the electrons
that are involved in bonding
sit on the arsenic,
and all the orbitals on
the gallium are empty.
And so with this microscope
we can send electrons
into the empty orbitals,
and take them out in two
different measurements
of the filled orbitals,
and really look at where the electrons are
and where they aren't,
kind of like no theater.
And that turns out to be just
the way an atom or molecule
cruising along the surface
would see that surface,
and it lets us explore and
understand the chemistry
with better than atomic resolution,
as if we could put on goggles
that show us the chemistry of a surface.
So that led to many,
many other capabilities.
One of the things I did when I was at IBM
was I wanted to find out what
was underneath those atoms,
so I rewrote the software on a microscope
to slide them out of the way.
I didn't spell anything,
that came after I left,
but that let us position atoms
and formed these precise structures,
like this famous quantum corral image,
where I'll point out all these waves
are not extra atoms.
They're just the electrons
interfering with each other,
as if we threw a rock in a calm pond.
And so we now understand
the chemistry that results
from having those extra electrons
right in the middle there.
There will be a molecule
that would wanna sit
at that one particular point,
not because of any special
chemistry of what's underneath.
Everything is the same, it's all copper,
but we changed the chemistry
there by these manipulations.
We can play a Newton's cradle game too.
That's another story.
There should be one more.
Okay.
We have a lot to learn from each other.
Just as Muybridge, 130 years ago,
took these stop-frame images of a horse
to prove that all four
hooves left the ground
at any give time,
in what Professor Ghez does and what I do,
we get glimpses of what we're looking at,
and how we interpret
what happens in between
is all important to our understanding.
So one of the great benefits
of being in a place like this
is I could work with a filmmaker
and go through what are
the rules of animation,
which Disney put together
in a bible some years ago,
so we could understand what
the possibilities were,
both in how atoms and molecules
move across a surface,
but also so that how
we could understand it
in our own heads,
how we would display it to control,
modify, inform our perception.
Okay?
And so, I think part of
this community that we have
is really an opportunity for us to
learn from each other and share,
and thank you so much for including me
in this wonderful event.
Thanks.
(audience applause)
- [Brett] Thanks, Paul.
- [Paul] Thank you.
- [Brett] Rodrigo.
- [Rodrigo] I'm just
gonna play video first,
and then I'm gonna talk.
Can you dim the lights now please?
(narration in Spanish)
So, I don't know if you get
everybody to see the subtitles.
I was thinking a lot about space,
and I think some of the
questions I sent people
is probably is the less romantic version
of the conversation about
space that you can have
is when you have not enough space, right?
It's like, as I think in the art
and in many institutional spaces
as a person of color you feel like
there is enough space for one,
but two becomes a lot,
so it's like, how can rooms
become oppressively small,
even if they are really large in size.
How you find these spaces to become...
Like I'm translating any word that has
so much romantic charge
into something more simple,
most tangible, like saying room, right?
They don't have enough room
is something that you hear a lot.
Like it's space is almost have like...
I like to translate words
into something very simple
and very attainable.
So I just want to show
you two examples of words
I've been thinking about
when somebody invites me
to do something in a room,
because basically it's like,
they invite you to fill up white walls
when you make art, right?
There's like, put stuff there,
any stuff.
Like we need this guy that
makes work about something else,
you know, that...
So...
The lights, can you turn the light out?
Can you just put the lights out?
People don't need to see me for this.
(audience laughing)
So, thinking about the space,
I enter museums where
I feel my job is trying
to disrupt the harmony
like European art have
had over the course of,
you know, a solid 600 years.
(laughing)
You go to places where they tell you
you can have the whole museum
to make work, to put stuff,
and then, like, but
already have so many stuff.
Can I just use your stuff?
And then it's my ideas?
And which also relate to the idea,
it's like, what is the
work made of, right?
It's like, a lot of...
I mean, I'm guilty of this
where I'm busy all the time
and I don't have time to make new work,
and considering that moving
your hands is only the form
of labor that we appreciate,
the intellectual labor
is really hard labor.
And your ideas, and the only
way that you can manifest
your ideas filling up spaces with stuff
is by moving your hands a lot.
So you enter another conversation
about economic placement,
where how much worth are my ideas
versus somebody else's ideas.
Like what is their space,
what is the collection goals?
Who owns those pieces?
Which other space is
this, and have it, right?
So in this museum they have...
I need to find the common
denominator for the spaces
to understand what I'm
doing in this museum,
in this case was at the
Jordan Schnitzer museum
in Eugene, Oregon.
And basically every,
you know, we're lucky,
we have a very prestigious institution
where we have the hammer.
They have an amazing collection,
and some (mumbles) art.
But in general, every
university has their own museum,
and every small town have their museum.
The only thing that they have in common
is that they all have terrible
American landscape paintings.
(audience laughing)
They all have the same thing.
So, to me it was like,
how is when European guys
make a painting, it's sublime,
and Latinos make it,
it's picturesque, right?
This is how we access
that space of aspiration,
aspirational, philosophical
concerns, right?
How we can become that guy?
So in this case,
I grab the walls from a past exhibition,
and I access the permanent
collection of the place,
and I conceal all the permanent collection
of these paintings in the space,
so I grab all the work that they own.
And if you remember a little
bit of the script of the...
The movie, how I made it
is I shot it with people,
and I didn't know what
the work was really about,
so I went in this stream
of consciousness speech
where I was talking to a Microsoft phone
as I watched the movie,
and the movie is about this...
It's called Tertiary,
which is the third characters in a movie.
Secondary characters is
the best friend, you know?
Maybe the guy that have one line.
But the other people are the
background actors, right?
The tertiary is the people
that have the job name,
you know, Cop One, Clerk One,
and usually those people are
the people of color, right?
They need to fill up the
movies with people of color
so the scene look real.
Right?
But they have no talking parts.
You know, so like in a way the movie
and this piece is about that.
So it's like, I don't need to make
a better landscape than that.
I just need to put it in front.
I just don't want...
Like, I don't need to...
There is plenty of mediocre
dudes there, you know?
Can I suck characters?
Can I suck for a little bit?
Can I go and make a mediocre landscape?
So it's like, but put it in front.
So you have to see my
work through the walls
or through the other,
so it's a matter of
priorities right now, to me.
It doesn't need to be better,
it just need to be presented fierce.
In the same way you have
placed the other guys fierce
all the time.
Or like you have surrendered
the spaces of the walls.
You have filled it up.
There is balls of stuff
that they make no sense,
they have no meaning
beside that one guy wanted
to paint the landscape.
And it was sublime.
And he's experienced.
So yeah, I went to Zabriskie
Point, I shot this.
In another situation, I was in this,
where this actually was my
first museum show, in Seattle.
The Friar Museum, they have this beautiful
salon style permanent collection.
Fucking amazing room, it's beautiful.
It's the museum that
you take your grandma,
and you just have a lovely afternoon.
(audience laughing)
You know?
Look at the things, you know?
They are naked but they're
not really sexual, right?
They're like, really, really, beautiful.
And the walls are really nice.
So basically, when I had the show,
you know, Seattle is changing a lot,
there is all this construction and stuff.
So I decided, well, there
is a place that we go,
this space that we try to get knowledge,
and it's always look the same.
So what I did,
I just transformed the whole space.
There is the room.
I just left the scaffolding,
I make graffiti on the walls,
and I made these images,
this city of forest
called hedonic reversal,
which is like searching pleasure for pain.
That is what it means, hedonic reversal.
And so I just...
This is the same room,
where I left the work, the
paper that they cover the floors
to protect it, I just covered
the whole place in graffiti.
I left the scaffolding.
And in some way, we want to go to spaces,
and we want to try to suck knowledge,
but not all gonna look
like this white cubes.
They're not gonna be
alienating for people that
haven't historically belonged
to those white cubes.
So I just wanna be able to go to places
and suck up knowledge,
independently of how they look.
So yeah, that is the exhibition where I...
That is two examples,
and that is the theory, you know?
Where, again, I shoot photos,
and I shoot in my studio,
no have a big studio,
so I shoot and re-shoot,
which is a different
conversation about space,
where the idea of space happen
in the photographic realm,
where things are...
The photo have a time that imply
in the time that you
spend with the other photo
that you re-photograph later.
So you allow yourself to kind of
improve on the work that you did,
without changing space,
but still there is a
psychological space that you enter
when you look at these images,
because you know that time passed.
You just don't know when.
So those are kind of the
two samples of the work
that kind of follow the line of that video
in the way that I understand space
as seen as a place I wanted to fix,
and not consider that is a given,
you know, for you, but...
When I enter a space I think
how many Latinos there are,
how many black people there are,
and then it's like,
and sometimes it's just not enough,
and sometimes it's just too many,
and who dictate those places?
It is a lot of the power
of the institutions,
and those are the things
that we all need to
keep accountable and
control and remind them
of the power,
the way that they control knowledge.
So it's important for me to evidence that
with this project.
But yeah, that's it.
- [Brett] Terrific.
Thank you.
(applause)
Dana.
- [Dana] Here I go.
Maybe.
(laughs)
Let's see.
It's this one.
Okay, yeah.
All right.
So, I'm gonna just stand up
because my neck is getting a
crank from looking behind me.
Architecture is space.
In 10 minutes it's gonna
be about 700 years,
so that gives me about
1.3 minutes per century,
so it's gonna be fast.
(audience laughing)
I have a little argument,
so that complicates my 10 minutes.
And that is that there is no such thing
as architectural space,
except for as we think
about it historically,
and so I wanna take you from
the modern subject,
or modern space,
which is a really 20th Century idea,
to contemporary space in Los Angeles.
I would say that that's
the movement through space
as abstraction.
That's the modern era,
that that goes into a post-war
space of transformation,
and that we're currently
in a period in which
we can think of space
productively, as reclamation.
What do I point out?
Okay. So, in order to do
that I have to give you
a slight pre-history because
the space of abstraction
doesn't mean much unless you
think about where it came from,
which was really the
Renaissance idea of space,
and it's Brunelleschi who either discovers
or rediscovers the idea of perspective,
and in that it turns
out that of course space
is a kind of mathematics,
and that we can actually
develop a science of space
through the process of its representation,
and that the construction
of three dimensions
into two dimensions,
which you see so beautifully
rendered in this etching,
actually helps in the construction
of particularly spectacular
and innovative buildings,
like the Duomo in Florence
that Brunelleschi himself made.
During this period,
Sigfried Giedion, who wrote the book
Space, Time and Architecure in 1941,
says that the ultimate example
of Renaissance and perspectival space,
is really the City of Paris,
with Haussmann's and Napoleon III's help.
And you see in this before and after image
how the city becomes a
kind of outdoor room,
a kind of space that you
would say is the city of form,
according to the architect
and urbanist Albert Pope.
And you can think about that city of form
as being almost an excavation
through the mass of buildings,
out of which streets or
piazzas of plazas are made.
And so the city is almost a thick mat
in which space can be discovered,
or excavated.
And in this reconstruction I
think it's important to note
we often think of Haussmann and Paris
as being its boulevards.
But what makes the boulevard
is Haussmann's housing blocks,
the apartment blocks that he made
that became the urban filler in a way
to lead you to the perspectival
object of your affection
at the end of the vista,
or at the end of the
one point perspective.
The other thing that's I
think worth noting in this
is that it brings the
subject into the view
because we have a single point of view,
we have a location in the
perspectival Renaissance city.
You see this best standing
right in the middle
of the Champs-lyses.
Oh...
Oops, the wrong direction.
We need to get up in history.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so, here we are in modern space.
I think the contrast between,
say, what Haussmann in Paris
and Brunelleschi were making,
and this Bauhaus image
from the painter actually,
Oskar Schlemmer,
situates the figure as a
kind of abstract entity
in an abstract space
that extends forever in every direction
outward from him, I think.
And so that figure seems to be
both central and dislocated somehow,
in this space that is in fact the focus
as a form of abstraction.
I feel like...
Hmm, this is unlikely to run.
Can you make that video run?
- [Crew Member] It's going.
- Ah, perfect.
So here's the way Oskar
Schlemmer made that into a dance,
by showing that in fact...
This is called a pole dance,
you can imagine what else
I found on the internet
while I was looking for
this. (audience laughing)
The figure is really erased
in order to become the vehicle
to demonstrate abstract space.
And this kind of beautiful demonstration
of the way space itself might look
is what Schlemmer was trying to achieve.
Can we go forward?
Yes, before the pole
dance ads come up after.
(audience laughing)
So really the master
of modern architecture
as anyone in the room who's
an architecture student
would know is Le Corbusier,
who writes in a book called
The Making of Modern Space.
Let me make sure I have
that title correct.
He writes, "A boundless depth opens up.
"It faces the walls, drives
away contingent presences,
"accomplishes the miracle
of ineffable space."
And I think even in that language,
Corbu was a beautiful
writer as well as architect.
He portrays this notion of an abstraction
that the architect then
was there to try to capture
as this almost existential,
ineffable task,
which the Ozanne Pond Studio I think
is a perfect example of...
This is in the book
The New World of Space.
But Corbu thought that the major arts,
which he defined as
architecture, sculpture,
city planning, and painting or drawing,
were in fact all united and major
because they were all about space.
And so you see in his Ville Radieuse,
the city itself is a plane of space
out of which architecture is situated.
The Villa Savoye which is the example
of spatial manipulation by the architect
that he's freed the ground
plane by raising it up
on columns or piloti,
that he's freed the
facade by separating it
from the structure,
and that he's freed the barrier
between the inside and outside
through the strip window
that distributes light evenly throughout.
And that same freedom he
captures in that drawing
which is left open, and though a boundary,
is not at all bounded.
So if you think about modern space
as being the space of the city
and now I'm gonna leap from
the building to the city,
Los Angeles itself is part of the object
of modernist urban spatial thinking.
And Bunker Hill is probably
our best example of that,
which in fact, in the
50s and 60s and the 70s
was flattened and cleared,
turned into a tabula
rasa, or a clean slate,
so that the new modern abstract space
could be built upon it.
This is just one plan of many,
many plans that were made
that would bring Los
Angeles into the modern era
through its architectural composition.
It's important to note even here though
that the freeways are part
of what is constructing
that space of the city.
And probably the person who
brought that to our minds
most clearly was the British
architectural historian
Reyner Banham, who wrote the book:
Los Angeles, Architecture
of Four Ecologies.
And he thought that the freeways,
of course he's writing in the late 60s,
publishes it in the 70s
when you could actually get
from one place to another
on the freeway,
(audience laughing)
that he writes that that's
his whole space of existence.
The freeway system in its totality
is now a single comprehensible place,
a coherent state of mind,
a complete way of life,
the fourth ecology of the Angelino.
And I bolden the place,
because it's the way we have distinguished
in most recent history,
space from place,
that somehow space is
something that exists
and can be passed through
or extends abstractly
from this world, place
is a site of dwelling.
And he was making the point
that in fact the freeways
were a site of dwelling.
What he didn't acknowledge
is that the freeways
wiped out dwellings everywhere they went,
and that that was their national task.
And in fact we can see that
the Boyle Heights neighborhood
has been particularly victimized
both by the East L.A. interchange,
but also by the 101,
as a means of eradicating
poor neighborhoods of color.
And so the politics of space
really starts to play into
this next era of both transformation,
and of what we'll later call reclamation.
You see up at the upper right
the neighborhood of Boyle Heights
that sits under and
next to the 101 freeway
and this you can see in one short year
is in fact the transformation
into a new and modern
housing development design
by the son of Frank Lloyd Wright,
and some of his colleagues.
This is public housing.
All public housing also had to be located
one for one elimination
on top of what were deemed slums,
which was a political determination,
always disadvantaging
neighborhoods of color.
So now, with that hard history behind us,
how do we move forward in
the City of Los Angeles,
which if Paris was a city of form,
what Albert Pope has suggested
and I think we've seen
in the other images,
Los Angeles is a city of space.
We basically live on a field condition,
a plane in which sprawl
has been the space of our
transformation and production.
And now, finally, after
decades of asking for this
as an urbanist and architect,
we're building back in.
And what we're having
to do is reclaim space
that has otherwise seemed
not available to us.
And I'm here just gonna
show you one project
that Brett alluded to in his introduction,
and that's this space
of the backyard home,
or the secondary unit,
which is a project that cityLab,
my center has been working
on for a dozen years.
So if L.A. can double the density
of its single family neighborhoods
by adding backyard homes,
it will become a model
of a post-suburban city,
transformed through discovered space
for affordable housing
with no public funding.
Given the nature of our housing crisis,
the reclaiming of lost
space for our residents
is an absolutely critical
task for the architect.
Okay.
Can you change...
Oh, perfect.
So, what we see is that there
is this kind of found space
that was in backyards that
can grow steadily over time.
They can do that without
changing neighborhoods,
and that there's an increment,
a molecule of urbanism, if
my colleagues will allow me,
that something like the small house,
which itself is a didactic transformation,
or adaptation of the two car garage,
that we would in fact
decide to house people
better than cars.
And so that little house
that we built on the campus
is exactly that same footprint,
and is intended to be a
reclaimed space for occupancy.
And like the stacking in nanoscience,
I'm trying to make some
connections that'll maybe
bring us together in our conversation.
Oops, we went one too far.
Those small increments
actually adapt a huge change,
if there are eight million
single family houses
in California.
This is the most radical
transformation of our landscape
of the space of our state
that's happened since World War II.
There are many, many other
spaces to be reclaimed and found,
whether it's surface parking,
or underutilized school campuses
where it's still, again,
we can repurpose that space
and reclaim it for making our
city a better place to live
for all of our residents.
Thanks.
(audience applause)
- [Brett] Thank you.
Thank you, Dana.
Andrea?
- [Andrea] All right.
Passing of the baton.
(laughs)
- [Dana] If you touch
just the forward and back
it seems to work.
I think I was pressing the wrong button
at one time.
- Okay.
Great.
Well, if you ask an
astrophysicist what space is,
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna tell you three things.
It's really big (laughs),
it's very humbling,
and it's connected to time.
So those are the three things
I hope to share with you.
It's also, in astronomy,
actually astronomy's one
of the oldest sciences
because we have an amazing
ability to study space.
With just your eye,
which of course is one of our,
gives us one of our five senses,
we can see well beyond the
boundaries of our own galaxy
to the next closest galaxy.
And if you compare that to
any of our other senses,
that's rather astounding,
how far we can smell,
how far we can taste,
how far we can hear.
But our ability of sight
really brings space
that's very large to us.
Now, people have been studying astronomy
for a very long time.
But today, the study of astronomical space
as is carried out with
very large telescopes.
So I have to share with you
one of the wonderful
aspects of being at UCLA
is that UC owns the largest
telescopes in the world.
These are co-owned by UC and Caltech.
They're not in a bad space here on Earth.
They're out in Hawaii,
so most of the folks here at UCLA
carry our their work
with these telescopes.
So it used to be that we
had to go up to the summit,
but in fact now you can
control these facilities
here from UCLA.
Now, telescopes allow us to see very far.
The bigger the telescope,
the larger the collecting area
so you can see things that are faint.
And in astronomy,
faint corresponds to
things that are far away.
So that's one aspect of distance.
Another aspect of distance,
because space we usually
think of as three dimensions,
but of course, if you're a
physicist, you might think:
well maybe not, maybe
it's nine, 10, or 11,
and we can debate about that,
but we're gonna today stick
to three dimensions of space
and one dimension of time.
So my thinking about
space is four dimensional.
So we have distance,
which is our distance away from us,
and then in a plane of the sky,
what we see out in the universe,
there's two dimensions of space,
and then of course there's time.
So we're gonna come back to time.
Now, this is the humbling part.
(laughs)
It used to be we thought we
were the center here on Earth.
We thought space surrounded us
and that we were at
the epicenter of space.
But of course, with Galileo,
Galileo who was committed to house arrest
for this radical notion that we were not
at the center of everything,
we now recognize that the Earth
is just one of many planets
that orbit the sun,
which in fact is quite ordinary.
So in fact we had a phase
where we thought the sun was special.
But now we realize not even the sun
that we orbit is special.
Our galaxy is composed of roughly
100 billion stars like the sun.
The sun you can think
of as a middle age star,
ready to go out and get
that red sports car.
(audience laughing)
It's five billion years old.
It's halfway through its lifetime,
which is also another humbling
thought in terms of space.
Our sun, when it runs
out of gas, and it will,
in another five billion years,
is going to expand.
So we live in a dynamic universe,
and it will expand to envelop the Earth.
So if you ever forget what
order the planets come in
just remember the TV show
Third Rock From The Sun,
or Third Rock, because we are
the third rock from the sun.
So at some point the sun
will actually envelop us,
which actually I think really drives us
to think about exploring space.
Can we get off this rock and go further?
Because there will be a moment,
if we manage to survive,
where we will need to
explore the larger universe
by moving.
All right, so in our
universe, we not only,
we have the sun, and
we said that there's...
The sun is pretty typical,
and now we have the
ability to recognize that
the stage that the sun
is in is pretty boring,
actually it's pretty
static, fortunately for us.
But there are some really
interesting and dynamic parts
of a star's life.
Just like a human's life,
the most exciting parts tend to be
the beginning and the end.
So in the beginning,
this is a picture that shows
the beginning of stars' lives.
And if you go further with this analogy
with a human lifetime,
the birth of a star
compared to the age of
a typical star's life
is like a human gestation period.
So on stars' timescales,
this is a few million years of time passes
as the star goes through
the process of collapsing
from enormous scales,
down to the size of our
sun and our solar system.
So this is the beginning.
Now, just like humans,
the end is also exciting.
We already alluded to the end of the sun,
but in fact our sun is
a fairly small star,
and it ends its life...
Well, while we say it's gonna be dramatic
because it's gonna envelop the Earth,
in an astronomical sense it's
actually rather non-dramatic.
The massive stars are
the ones that explode.
This is a picture of an exploding star.
So we have a dynamic
(mumbles) nervous again
because if we go from
things at the beginning
that are shrinking to at the
end where things are expanding,
and expanding quite explosively.
And in this explosion,
it's actually where we get
the chemical complexity
that we so appreciate here on Earth.
Our universe starts off
with incredible simplicity.
It's just hydrogen.
And out of the inner workings of stars
we can build up to more
chemical complexity,
up to iron, but in fact iron
is a pretty simple atom.
And it's only in these
exploding massive stars
that we get all the complexity
that we so appreciate here,
like gold, or anything
that your cellphones
are created from,
are created in these
explosions of massive stars.
Now we've gone from a point where we said
the Earth was the middle, to
the sun that was the middle.
And then a mere hundred years ago,
and to me this is rather amazing,
100 years ago we thought
our own galaxy was it.
(laughing)
And today, we recognize that our galaxy,
and if we could get outside
our own galaxy and look back,
this is what our galaxy would look like.
We live about halfway out.
It's just one of many, many, many,
billions and billions of galaxies,
(laughing)
as many others have said.
The galaxy that I was just
showing you a moment ago
is the one in the top left.
So today we understand that in fact
there's a universe that's on
a much, much larger scale.
So in the last mere hundred
years of our history
we've come to understand the
vastness of the universe.
Now, (laughs)
(audience laughing)
we collect this information
primarily through telescopes.
We're collecting light, or photons,
which are little light packets.
And it turns out that these light packets,
these carriers of information,
do not travel at infinite speed,
but they travel at the speed of light,
which we actually think of
as the cosmic speed limit.
Nothing can go faster in our universe
than the speed of light.
But this means that as
we study the universe,
we're not seeing it as it is today,
but rather as it is when that photon
that you're collecting
was emitted from it.
And because we are now studying
scales that are so big,
what we're really getting
is a history lesson.
And to give you a sense of this,
I study the center of the galaxy.
That's my favorite place
in the universe to look at.
The light from the center of
the galaxy takes 26,000 years
to get from the center of
the galaxy to our telescopes.
So I have to say I'm very excited
about an event that's happening,
just culminating now
over the last six months.
But that six months
happened 26,000 years ago.
Okay, so that's already
mind blowing to me.
But that's nothing in astrophysics.
So once we get going to
the next closest galaxy,
we're talking two million years ago.
That's the light that we're collecting.
And when we talk about
the edge of the universe
that we can see today,
we're looking back 14 billion years ago.
So in fact we're not seeing
these places in space (laughs)
as they are today, but
as they were so long ago.
So that's one way in which space
is highly connected to time.
Now there's another way in which
space is connected to time,
and that's if you get near objects
that have large gravitational fields.
My favorite subjects in
the universe to study
are black holes.
Turns out there's a
super massive black hole
at the center of the galaxy (laughs)
or a million (laughs)
times the mass of the sun,
crammed into a space the
size of our solar system.
So, lots of mass, small space,
that's the proof of a black hole.
But why do we care about it in the context
of this discussion?
We care about it in the
context of this discussion
because when you get near black holes
or any object that has
a gravitational field,
you get this mixing of space and time.
So if you go to any science museum,
there's the classic gravity well,
and that's supposed to
represent the concept
of two dimensions of space being mixed.
They flatten that one dimension of space
with one dimension of time.
So, if you were to send your buddy,
or maybe not so much your buddy,
into the black hole,
(audience laughing)
you would see your buddy
get slower and slower
and then pause at a magic
distance from the black hole
known as the event horizon.
They'd just stop.
And that's because it's
very hard for the photon
that's the carrier of
information to make it
from them to us.
It's the mixing of space-time.
Your buddy, his experience,
or her experience,
would be to get faster and faster
and go right through the event horizon.
So that is an aspect of space
that I find particularly fascinating.
I'm just gonna skip over these things.
Just to share that our ability
to study space and time
is advanced by having larger
and larger telescopes.
So UC has had the largest
telescope in the world
for 100 years.
The Keck telescope is just
the latest and greatest.
It's been around for 25 years.
But we're in the middle of building
an even bigger telescope.
It is a 30 meter telescope,
which we hope will be built in Hawaii,
and it's a collaboration between
the University of
California, Caltech, Canada,
Japan, China, and India.
So that brings is into
other connections of space,
and connectivity in the world
that brings us back to a human scale.
So thank you very much.
(audience applause)
- [Brett] Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Indeed, thank you, all four of you.
As an audience member
that was just awesome.
(panel laughing)
Really fantastic.
I don't know, I arrived a little late
and I can't remember how
the order was sorted,
but let me just say there
was some inspiration
in this idea of going from the molecular
to the room, or gallery,
to the city, and to the galaxy.
So our work is done.
We have covered the spectrum.
(audience laughing)
That's really interesting.
And of course that would beg
follow on questions immediately
about the negotiating role of an idea
of scale or size in relation
to a concept like space,
that I think each of you
touches on really interestingly.
But to throw an immediate
question out for each of you,
and maybe so that you can respond
to other things heard on the stage,
I'm struck by the way in which each of you
touched on the importance
of a particular kind of tool
from which you then spoke about space.
So in some cases, a kind of
technology, a microscope,
a telescope, a tool in the
sense of an institution
or a museum as being
a vital idea of sight,
that then a project reacts to.
And in the case of the city, Dana,
the notion of a map or
a geography described
through various
representational conventions.
Could you say something
about your daily lives
and routines around the
way in which the tools
that are clearly a part of your lives
help you think about the
work that you're doing?
Or does all that sort of sit on the side
as we just sit in the world
of ideas and concepts?
- [Dana] Well, I can't think
without representational tools,
period.
I mean, I have to have
diagrams that both reduce
the kinds of information that
is spurious and competing,
and that takes the scale of whatever it is
that I'm looking at, and synthesizes.
So, mapping has turned out to be a...
If you think of mapping broadly,
and the process of mapping,
has turned out to be a really fundamental
part of my work now.
I mean, it seems to me
that, Andrea, yours is,
you have to have the biggest tool,
because that's, I mean, this
must be like a political act.
My command of the tool is
also mostly in my power.
But in your case it would seem like
it's absolutely outside your power.
- [Andrea] We have a very
collaborative space (laughs).
- Yeah.
- In working with these
very large telescopes,
because it's a huge investment
so you have to share that tool.
Another connection though
is our desire to map.
So we are definitely making maps,
and our ability to visualize
the information or the space
really affects your
ability to understand it.
An animation that I skipped
was our ability to map out
these orbits that are in three dimensions,
and see them from different perspectives,
because of course in two dimensions
you have a very different understanding
about the space between objects,
which is enormous, but
they seem to overlap
when you only look at it in projection.
- Most of our time is spent
building or fixing tools.
(laughing)
It's the feast at the end
of preparing massively
for that time when you can record data,
or develop a new capability
that you get to see from the outside.
But, for instance, there is a microscope
we've been trying to make
work for 29 years now.
(laughs) And we're getting closer,
but the student who was
working on it just graduated
so we'll start a new PhD.
You know, you learn things along the way,
but we come up with a
problem we wanna solve,
and then we try and
develop a tool to do that,
whether it's understanding chemistry,
or light coming out of
an object and so forth.
I mean, one advantage...
I have a very bad sense of direction.
So, a nice thing about the nano scale is
we make it so everything
looks the same everywhere,
so you can choose any part
and sort of get the statistics you need.
We don't have to find the
star that does this, or...
And so, we can find, you
know, here's the arrangement
we wanted to see many times repeated,
and then do the measurements and discover
that they all behave differently,
and even individuals
could change over time.
So the fun comes at the end,
but there's a lot of work
that goes every day, yeah.
- [Brett] Rodrigo.
- I mean, it's interesting being able to
continually use tools
that look like the tool
that is required for the job.
I have to encounter a lot where
the tools I use to make art,
like I spend a lot of time
in Home Depot, and I spend...
All the things that you make work,
they have a patina that
they are not art, right?
And you conduct meaning from
things into something else.
Like in my space, I have white walls,
and the only conditions
of the world I make there
is that you need to be
able to leave the room.
That's like, that is the
only condition of the world
to be made inside the
studio that at some point
I have to get it through the door.
And that is like the only
scale that is important.
(audience laughing)
So all the things that happen there,
and all the potential of the buildings,
the materials that I use,
I use a lot of clay...
I'm a photographer but I use
clay, I use wood, I use metal,
and as you saw I use graphite,
I use all the materials that they are made
for other situations that are
not necessarily art sometimes.
So it's interesting thinking
about how everything start
in art in a more unfinished way,
and you surrendered yourself
with cultural gravitas
or material memory,
things like that that will
make a work of art work,
like be performing as a cultural object.
Now, I'm interested in this, I mean,
thinking about low income
housing, or you know those idea,
they have a house project in Chile,
the Chilean architect
that makes the houses
after the earthquake, he gives half house.
- [Dina] It's Aravena.
- Yeah, like Aravena, yeah, right.
And it's like something
that people can finish,
you know, it's like
something that people can go
and buy their own materials
to customize their house,
so you build it enough to
make a cheap but sustainable,
and then you can just,
as you make money through your lifetime,
you can customize it and fix it.
And it's a really interesting project,
that you could just look at it,
it's like, some of them not
an interesting piece of work.
You know, it's like,
and when they are empty
they are full of potential.
So I like that about this point,
but it's a place where they
have more potential than beauty,
and that is usually an
interesting junction of art
in some way.
- [Dana] It's interesting to think about
whether you can construct
a work that's not finished.
- Yeah.
- And I think
that's not been a long
history in architecture,
when you think of it having
to be somehow completed.
But that project in particular
was kind of brilliant,
in that it expected it to keep changing
and evolving and growing.
- Which is, as a comment,
touches on this idea of
a space of production,
or a project's reception,
which I'm interested in
everybody's case here.
You all, other than this Tuesday evening,
are speaking to audiences
of a very different form than this one.
I was gonna ask a question
about what it means
to come to an audience like
this and speak about your work
and your ideas about
a question like space,
versus what that audience is like
in your daily working lives,
or the public efforts that
you make to explain that work
to different kinds of audiences.
- [Paul] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
Shall I?
- Yeah.
- Well, I mean, they're very
different groups we speak to,
so there are times when
it's, you know, clinicians
trying to edit genes, and we
have some efforts we do there,
and that's a very knowledgeable community
on what they wanna do, and what
their current problems are.
There are other much more diverse groups
where it could be people
who come from any field
and lack the chemical background
where it's straightforward explanations of
here's what we're trying to do and why,
a matter, here is what we like.
We do a fair amount of public work too,
trying to say we're exploring this world
where people haven't been before,
and it just opened up in
the last 30 years to us,
and there's still a tremendous
amount we don't know,
and we don't know what it feels like.
Gravity doesn't matter.
Capillary forces do.
What are the other rules
we don't understand yet?
And that, just saying why we do what we do
ends up being really a
part of the conversation.
- [Brett] Andrea.
- Well I think astronomy
is an interesting field
because I often think of
it as the gateway science.
It's the gateway drug, it's
the beginning (laughs).
We live in a highly technological society,
and yet, unfortunately,
we're also incredibly phobic
of math and science.
So I think astronomy and
astrophysics has this societal role
in bringing the language
of science and technology
to the public.
So as a result, you see a
lot of astronomers who are
incredibly committed to this
public engagement piece.
- [Brett] Yeah.
- So I engage in a lot of this
not only because I think it's important,
not only because I think
in terms of understanding
what a scientist looks like,
but also because these
telescopes are really expensive.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
And it's really important that we engage
a lot of different audiences.
And now, actually there's
another interesting issue,
coming back to your other
question about space.
We wanna build this in Hawaii.
And now there are communities in Hawaii
that are no longer so
excited about being viewed
as a place of colonization.
So also astronomy has now taken
on this other, I'd call it,
it's like a lightning post.
It's a big project that symbolizes
this western kind of taking over.
So all of a sudden astronomers
are being put in this
position of talking about
why it's good to make these
investments in science.
And as we use these
telescopes in different ways,
we are becoming more removed,
which is removing us
spatially from that community.
So now all of a sudden
we're spending a lot of time
thinking about how can we
get back into that space
where actually the telescope is?
So I guess I find myself increasingly,
while I spend a lot of
time obviously thinking
about the technical (laughs),
and speaking to scientists
and technical people,
this idea of public dissemination,
public engagement is
increasingly important.
- I'm gonna open it up to the audience
in a couple of minutes time.
One of the topics though that came up
that I was really struck
by across the spectrum
of presentations is that a
different notion of space
than had been foregrounded
in the larger question,
which is a space of collaboration,
and not just production.
I'm really struck by the
different ways that you gave us
glimpses into very
different ways of working.
I mean, the expertise that
sits within your teams
in the research lab,
your work geographically
across distances between tools,
and in yourself, and collaborators
back in the laboratory,
the different constituencies
across the city,
and I'm just wondering if any
of you would have comments
on the extent to which
your thoughts around
the building of that
collaborative space is
in and of itself a kind of
project within your work.
- [Dana] Well there is
no making architecture
without a giant collaboration.
I mean, we were talking
about whether what precision
is like from nano scale
to architectural scale,
and I think I might make
the case that the precision
in architecture is absolutely dependent
on the collaboration.
Precision meaning that
you'd like to implement
the thing that you're
trying to create (laughs).
And that that thing
you're trying to create,
I mean, my first book was
about that being a negotiation,
not something that comes
from the fountainhead
of some individual creator.
And I think that we don't
think about that space
of collaboration as
creative practices enough.
And in my experience,
really that's kind of what
I've been most interestingly
involved with is
how you make something that's
really good and important,
with army, or crowd of actors.
- [Brett] Yeah.
Thank you.
- I kind of envy Rodrigo's
ability to manipulate a room,
even although I think
your audience is something
you're constructing all the
time as a bigger collaboration.
- Yeah, I mean, there is a
generosity that has to happen,
you know, as a...
I mean, I don't know how it
is in your guys' discipline,
but I rely on the students,
or my assistants sometimes,
or people to finish
the thought too, right?
That you present the
possibilities and ideas,
and there is so much I can
teach to students in art
that they are like, it's
not already inside them.
Like it's not within
them, their capacities.
You know, I can't tell you,
so you have to instigate
that curiosity for them
to figure out where is there space.
And the same with when I go these museums,
you know, I cannot even
touch anything, right?
There is a raised art, there is (mumbles).
So you have to trust that
everybody else want you
to also execute this criticality
I have about the spaces,
onto themselves.
You know, so you have to
first figure out how to
you're gonna convince
them that being critical
of the space where they work,
you're gonna be good
without getting fired.
So it's just like, it's
just this skill of finesse
and talking about the ideas
and how to contextualize them correctly.
That requires a lot of
communication skills.
And a lot of the time just to let people
throw your ideas to you,
and you're gonna respond more
than lecture and let people.
- [Brett] Yeah, terrific.
- [Paul] Mm-hmm, terrific.
Yeah, that actually is
where nanoscience came from.
We didn't have a field,
so we brought in people
from chemistry, physics, math,
engineering and medicine,
and said, "What problems do you care about
"that you can't solve?"
And then, "What approaches do you take
"and what tools do you
have and what do you need?"
And so the field developed
by teaching each other
language skills, and then--
- [Brett] Between the disciplines.
- Absolutely, yeah, and
between then experimental
and theory skills, and math,
we actually share not only the same math
but the same mathematicians
on our projects.
But that's also led us
out of the nano scale.
So, the brain initiative came
from nano scientists proposing it,
because we were curious
about how the brain worked.
And then microbiome initiative
also not really nano,
but we thought, well there
are a lot of missing tools
for how bugs talk to
each other in our mouths,
on our skin, in the ocean and the soil.
And so it really developed from
collecting a group of people
who had the language skills,
and then experts who had the
refractory problems to tackle.
That's been really the impact of the field
beyond making little things
and moving atoms around,
and trying to understand how
motors worked in biology.
- [Brett] And clearly a
capacity for translation
between forms of knowledge of--
- That's the sort of
interesting part of the--
- [Brett] They truly allow communication.
- Yeah, and hasn't happened in
other fields that we can tell
which we don't understand.
- Yeah, terrific.
- But it's part of the fun.
- [Brett] I think I'm getting
a signal that we can...
We have a couple of
microphones in the room,
and we really want this
to be an important part
of each of the sessions.
We can open it up to some questions,
for the next several minutes.
I don't know where the microphones are.
There we go.
And I see some hands coming up.
- [Student] Thank you
guys so much for the talk.
What do you think spirituality's
relationship to space is?
- Well, I'll take that one (laughs).
(laughing)
It turns out astronomers are
actually some of the most
religious, spiritual of the scientists,
and in fact there's an
interesting foundation
called the Templeton
Foundation that supports work
at the interface between
science and religion.
I think it's interesting to really...
I think the comment I made
about the humbling piece,
that you definitely get the
sense of something bigger,
it's so much bigger than we are,
both in terms of space and time.
It can't but leave you with
that sense of something bigger.
- On this side over here.
- [Student] I'd like to address this both
to Professor Cuff and Rodrigo.
You talked a lot about, you
didn't say the words exactly,
but transformation
re-utilization appropriation,
maybe those aren't the
right words, reclamation.
And the whole concept starting,
well, Hausmann, Corbu,
Bunker Hill, et cetera,
the freeways taking over
and so on and so forth,
and down to this concept
that you brought forth
which is the backyard home,
which is a space that was never used for,
well, it was used for a
garage to hold the car.
But the fact that it was
brought up a long time ago
but hasn't advanced very much, has it?
This whole concept of reusing space,
that you brought up, that
we need all over the world,
basically, but especially here in L.A.
- I'm not sure if you quite
understand what you mean
by advanced very much,
but I think the answer is no,
(laughs) it hasn't advanced very much.
And in fact, we learned about,
I mean, anyone can learn
about that space's reclamation
from watching what had
been going on in backyards
for the last 200 years, right?
We learned it from bottom up practices,
from vernacular practices.
There's really wonderful books and studies
about how people in Bell Gardens,
and other parts of the blue
collar life of Los Angeles
have always used their
residential space as
an income generating part of
their household economy, so--
- [Student] I was asking about this,
like how, with the number,
I don't know what that is,
wasn't that some special
ordinance that just--
- Yes, yes, that's the state
bill that we co-authored
to make legal all these secondary units.
- [Student] Because they
weren't legal before.
- That's right.
So they were all illegal.
And now we're trying to
figure out how to legalize
the ones that are already in existence.
I'm sorry I didn't make that clear.
There you go.
Yeah.
- Over here.
- [Student] Again, thank you very much
for a very, very great discussion.
I was wondering, you talked
about objects in space,
and on the micro level
and the macro level,
and about building in
space and defining space.
I was wondering if you
wanted to talk about
the other part of it,
which is this space itself,
which is the part the you're pinching on
of the objects existent,
which is also the name of
the committee itself, space.
I mean the focus of this.
It is the other element, the
one we haven't talked about.
- I mean, I think it's connected,
because the spaces are so
predetermined by these ideas
that come from the anthology of the world,
or the depending of what you are trying
to determinate as a space, right?
Like, as somebody was asking
about the spirituality,
there is often a space
where that happens, right?
There is like, you go to
a place that have walls
and that have a ceiling where
that spirituality happens,
and that is already charged
with a political history,
and a specific kind of traditions,
so in some way you enter...
There is almost any space,
like the Rutger Chapel
out in Houston, right?
It's full of paintings.
And you can enter, and I think,
I don't know who profits more
of the feeling of spirituality.
Maybe the artists gets
charged with something
that necessarily is not
intrinsic to purple paint.
So it's like just the artists
don't have a spiritual home,
have God on them, they're
acting like they had...
The artist definitely is not
touched by any mystery force.
So it's interesting when
the space is already charged
before you even consider them
what's gonna happen there,
like there is a certain
amount of activities
that can happen,
and in some way when I
make movies like that,
when in most of my movies,
I try to build the space
where actions can happen,
rather than predetermine
the actors to do it,
because people will
naturally respond to spaces.
Like everybody in the elevator
have elevator face, right?
They're like, you have
elevator conversations,
(laughing)
and you have elevator attitude, you know?
So like this, like this,
you're like, that's a space.
You know, there is no
such thing as small talk
in the middle of the desert.
You run into anyone in the desert,
and suddenly things become more profound,
when you have a conversation.
And any random comment that
some stranger will tell you,
if you encounter in the
middle of the desert,
I don't know why you're
gonna get closer to that guy,
but it will be like, "Holy
fuck, that means something."
(audience laughing)
And then you're gonna
walk around thinking,
trying to search for the
meaning of that one line
that some wandering guy give you.
So the spaces are like,
even if doesn't have walls,
are predetermined, and you
come conditioned to find
either spirituality, or
social cultural context.
I think it's already,
when we say the word,
they're already charged.
- [Dana] Mm.
- [Student] So, I have
a microphone (laughs),
so thank you very much
for presenting your ideas
on all these different scales.
My question was related to the question
that just happened about what's
going on inside the spaces,
so maybe we can expand to
hearing from the other speakers
about how space effects these
things inside the spaces,
in motion and direction and orientation,
and, yeah, movement.
We're in a place where there's
performances sometimes.
- [Brett] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- Andrea, one of your points,
it was really memorable,
it was this idea that you get a glimpse
into a universe in motion.
And that that isn't just a
motion in a room this scale,
but in fact...
- Well, yeah, you can
take this to the extreme,
the whole universe is in motion,
the idea that we started from a point,
and there was a big bang that
set the universe in motion.
I'll also leave you with
the thought of the fact
that most of space is empty.
There's actually nothing.
So while we give tremendous
value to these objects,
most of space is empty.
- Yeah, also--
- I'll give motion a go.
So, one of our inspirations is in nature.
There are motors that
can take chemical energy,
and convert it in motion with
better than 99% efficiency.
And there is nothing
humans make at any scale
that comes close to that.
And so, one of the goals in
my lab is to build structures
where we know where every atom is.
We go from quantum mechanics
to mechanical engineering,
and experiment, theory, and simulation,
and we figure out what
are the key components
of that ability to move.
So that's why we have these
smallest switches and motors,
and we can operate them, and
we had to build microscopes
to look at their function,
at the same time they
look at the structure,
at the same time that they
do other measurements,
and you alluded to
something in your question
of what's going on underneath the surface.
That turns out to be a hard
thing for us to measure,
but a goal for many, many years.
And so we developed a whole
series of tools to do that,
and we discovered this
sort of buried network
that affects properties very greatly.
There are pieces that
line up, pieces that move,
and we've come up with
ways to detect those,
and that adds an additional level
of interesting observations,
but also ways to control
and to make structures
that we wouldn't be able to do
just by putting two pieces
right next to each other.
So it turns out to be a whole...
You know, like uncovering
an ant colony or something.
We've learned a lot about
what's going on underneath,
and the dynamics, and
the structures that form,
and, again, not intuitive,
based on the macroscopic world around us.
- Thank you.
And Rodrigo has spoken on the topic.
Dana, you mentioned in your presentation
the idea of this very
modern, late modern idea
of the city in motion, the
freeway becomes a part of
our discourse in thinking about the city.
But it's clearly a very
different kind of motion
than might exist at either a chemical
or a physical universal scale.
- Yes, but I think architecture
is really about the intimacy
between the life within and
the thing that houses it.
I mean, really that is the
art form which doesn't exist
without the life within it,
whether that's something
you wanna describe
as emotion or process.
Maybe that's not quite
adequate to think about
the robust nature of our inhabitation.
But for certain,
that space, I think
that's one of the things
that is interesting in
looking at the history
of the notion of space,
is really it's a history
about the notion of the life
within the walls that we construct.
- Wonderful, we have a
couple of minutes left,
a couple of more urgent questions.
Up here on the left we have one.
- I found the whole concept of this,
the 10 questions fascinating,
because you picked words that
distilled, just like in the...
If you wanted to pick the
smallest particle in existence,
in many ways, words are
sometimes the smallest particles
of existence, as long as
you pick the right words,
and I think you guys have
done a pretty good job
picking these words.
So my question is to the panelists:
when you heard this word first, space,
did you have one idea in mind,
one definition of that word, or many?
And how did you go
about picking the anchor
that you were gonna latch
yourself onto for this discussion?
(panelist laughs)
- Thank you, that's terrific.
- I mean, I definitely
sent right way this idea
of knowing of a space.
I always think in maybe negative terms,
but, you know...
I mean, seeing the roster and considering
that there was people
that think about the space
in a very big way,
and the poetic connotations of space,
and thinking about the people
that it's so attached to time.
But where my brain goes right away is,
it's almost closer to Dana's research
where there is a time
and a space that happened
when you are poor, right?
There is like, poor people
get punished with time.
Longer commutes.
You know, like, more distance,
or you could make even
within the panel or the age,
and the kind of course, like
how far do we live from work?
And you can see the
social economic strategy
will be miles more from like, where is...
So there is a time and
a space is conditioning
in a non-poetic way to
how we cohabitate society,
and to me it was the first one
when you think about space,
and I was thinking, "Uff, not enough."
(laughing)
Not enough space.
- [Brett] Okay, that's not enough.
This is a great question.
First thing you thought of.
Andrea.
You get the invitation
from us, what is space?
- Well, beyond thinking
that's what I do (laughs)...
(audience laughing)
- This is great!
- Yeah (laughs).
- Yeah, yeah.
- I guess I thought it would
be interesting to talk about
our reference, our position in space,
our understanding of ourself
with respect to the space,
so that understanding
of not Earth-centric,
not solar-centric,
just this increasingly
large scale that we actually
have the ability to comprehend as humans.
- So, for me, it was trying to convey
getting to that unexplored world,
and yeah, I'll throw in
one thing and that is
astronomy was my gateway drug,
- (laughs) Excellent.
(audience laughing)
- to science, and until
I was eight years old,
my brother blew things up in the driveway,
and then I thought well, there
must be something interesting
in chemistry too (laughs).
(audience laughing)
- [Brett] What do you think, Dana?
- [Dana] I think I kind of panicked,
because like Andrea, I
think, that's what I do!
Like, I'm gonna explain in 10 minutes
the whole of architecture
and about what I do that...
And then I was like,
I went into research mode.
I started reading about Einstein,
and then I started reading the newspaper,
and thinking about silicone valley.
You know, people say, "I'm
gonna develop that space."
It was like--
(audience laughing)
How come everybody's got space?
I thought that was ours, in architecture.
(laughing)
So--
- [Brett] And they call
themselves information architects.
- Yes, I--
- That's even more...
- And they're designers, and
they're really advertisers.
(laughing)
You know, the whole thing
is just a subterfuge.
(laughing)
- Thank you.
Well, one more question I
think we've got time for.
Down here, please, down
front we've got a couple.
All right, we'll try
and squeeze in a couple
of more questions here.
- [Student] Thank you very much.
Professor Cuff, I was
really struck by your use
of the phrase lost space,
and I was curious maybe to hear
from the other three speakers
if they have a thought
about what lost space means to them.
- Yeah, I'm gonna try to be really short.
I think since we're in a
university, let's think very...
I mean, I work in a great institution,
and most of institutions have
a diversity mandate, right?
So if I apply to a job,
or if I try to go to a place where
maybe there's a limit for
the space of minorities.
There's a limit for space for any kind.
Like even if you have
too many white dudes,
there's gonna be a limit right now.
So it's like, when you
think about institutions
or mandates about the limits of that,
it may be that there is, or maybe one,
like if there was another
Latino photo professor,
there is no chance I
can get this job, right?
There's no chance I can get the job.
So like, that is the limit.
There is a limit of like
really what are the limits
that the institutions have self-imposed,
and the spaces have self-imposed, right?
So, like museums have a collection.
The collection have
necessities to complete itself,
like galleries have a roster,
there is enough artist of one kind,
or not enough of another kind.
So you have, there is always a limit,
and I think that is how you can understand
a lot of the rooms where you enter.
Where is the limit of them?
- So lost space, limited space...
One of the points you made,
Paul, at the very beginning
that was interesting,
it's this idea that you,
and I believe it was when you were showing
the Moy Bridge animation,
this idea that you occasionally
get glimpses of space.
There's a kind of active interpretation.
- Yeah, yeah, when we try in that,
we try and cover this,
but the factor of 100 billion in time,
without really being able to do that,
so we have to come up with
clever ways either to fill in
or take snapshots or something else.
I'll maybe go back to
your original comment
on the campus though.
So, one of the very
great advantages here is
we are at very high density,
and we do have the arts,
and science and engineering
and medicine all proximate,
and that's at a very unusual
aspect of the university,
and particularly of the
quality of the people
we have across all different areas.
So I feel like I've hit
a lot of the sciences
and engineering and a piece of medicine.
I have a few tentacles up here,
but I do feel like I'm missing...
I have a lot to learn as I mentioned
with the filmmaker at the end,
and some other
collaborations in that space,
if you don't mind me...
(laughing)
- [Dana] Just was I was thinking of.
- Yeah, I know, sorry (laughs).
You put it in my head and it stuck.
But I think we do have a
lot to teach each other,
and part of it is storytelling
and where we come from and why,
and how we think about space.
And I think you chose
very uncharacteristic...
I mean, we all look at
space in a different way
than I think most of the
people in our fields do.
That became clear.
So, I'm representative,
in some sense, it's good,
it expands everything, but I
think we have this opportunity
here at UCLA to reach out to each other,
and do things that nobody else can.
We found that in our technical work,
but there's much more to it
than that yet to come, I think.
- Terrific.
Andrea?
- I guess when I hear this question
I think about the windows
that we have into space,
that we're highly biased
by our historical ability
to get optical, what your eye detects.
That's where the first
instruments were developed.
But there are other windows
to different kinds of light.
What UCLA's really good at
is the detection of infrared light.
That's what we specialize in.
But there are other windows.
X-ray, gamma rays, and
that's all focused on light.
And now we're even opening up the concept
that you can detect gravitational waves.
So there are these different...
Coming back to this concept of diversity,
one needs a diversity of information
to paint the full picture,
otherwise you have a very biased view
on our understanding of the universe.
- Terrific, thank you.
I'm gonna use that last
round of four responses
to draw a close to this.
We've come to the end of the evening.
Thank you, the four of you,
thank you so much for being on
this side of the fourth wall,
for all of you for coming in
and spending part of your week
with all of us.
Thank you so much, everybody.
(applause)
Thank you.
Parts of this evening's
conversation touched upon
next Tuesday evening, which of
course will be: What Is Time?
Please come in and join us for that one.
Thank you everybody.